I was wearing a pixie the day before I
baked food and now we're in the red red
realm so is this a so it's a choice of
the multi the different color okay just
so happens to some fool in that kind of
spectrum I understand listen I saw the
footage and you guys look like you a
great chemistry that looks like a great
Christmas movie now what was it about
the project that pulls you in
which I can't really give away too much
it's an amazing town
Ameena clock place my office
she's absolutely not
we meet ok speakers is the main
olan hard times
I figure out who she hasn't proposed
they bump into each other
learn so much about each other
try to help each other
I have to ask you your life must have
dramatically changed over the last year
do you enjoy
I would imagine you've lost your
anonymity a little bit
crazy people have been
and also just how much they show you
and I can't wait to see
Rajani you guys saw which was absolutely
insane I hope that's the other thing I
wanted to bring up the footage from the
gentlemen it looks at vintage Guy
Ritchie oh yeah and I absolutely loved
every frame I saw and references I have
to ask you what was it like working with
these actors cuz it's an all-star
ridiculous line
you've drawn which you saw it all
never saying
never think that he would utter Michelle
Dockery Jeremy straw I mean
most mice interested for the Charlie and
Matthew is much like all
piracy stories
we've come back here
that one's going to be ribs
but the thing about guy and I've seen
him work is that he likes to change
things on the fly
see you prefers an actor having all your
dialogue memorized or do you like it
when he throws you a curveball and says
yeah everything that you learned is no
longer happening you need to say that's
I mean that's that's what happened
somewhere especially as an acting you
have to me
you are on
the director answered
if it changes the train
go to say knowing your life but also
understanding they can strongly
whole action the whole
that's where the magic
-
in that cooperative
so many slides that we came up with
traditionally
my last thing you gotta go are you
filming with the crazy [ __ ] agent
sequels back-to-back no what
Susy running away trying to
something probable they haven't told us
somewhere
thank you